[Music]
this is a butterfly in words so it's
opposite directions the planes are
overlapping and it looks like a
butterfly flapping its wings this is
what my favorite moves to teach because
it's such a good play fool move and it
usually goes pretty smoothly if you
start with play foo and we can do all
that in one lesson grab your pulley wrap
them up face me and you're gonna pretend
you there's a window in front of you
right so we're gonna mine that in this
window and just draw big inward circles
on that window and so you're not going
back here it's really on a wall playing
in front of you the best you can it's a
barbeque the smoke so inwards means
there the cross is coming down in the
front and notice as soon as you do it
and yet you can start really big and
then make it a little smaller but make
sure they're really overlapping so you
see that cross on the way down so if
there's a little hoop in front of you
the fingers are tracing the whole hula
hoop the whole time
notice set one of the arms has to be on
top right your left can be on top or
your right can be on top and whatever
hands gonna be on top pass this closer
to your face you can switch you can put
the right on top or the left on top and
if your right hand isn't you close your
face at top it's further from your
thighs at the bottom just notice that
and you know it'll be the simplest pie
you just have to pay attention thank you
my yellow poise closer to me at the top
further from me at the bottom
orange poise closer at the top further
at the bottom and that's why they don't
crash so the planes are not quite on a
wall plane right one of the planes has
bent towards you so it's closer at the
top and further at the bottom so the
planes would be
like this but you can that's something
you can put your mind around later right
now I just need you to do this universe
and then you can go the other way
Edwards same thing look at my yellow boy
if it's closer at the bottom its further
at the top and if the orange boy is
closer at the bottom its further at the
top so you guys alternate it or you can
repeat the same one come back to inwards
do some inwards and let it do a few just
pick one and do several kind of a toy
speed then you're gonna let your play
out but really short just really really
really short and do the same thing at
poi speed and if they're really quite
short they they won't tangle you might
have to be really really short but if
your hands aren't hitting the poi won't
hit and here they this is it's so easy I
used to be a tough move to teach but you
know we have these new move learning
technologies and methods that make it
easier so you start and what you're
gonna do is you're just going to slowly
let the play be longer and this might be
over the course of a few days and then a
little longer and just relax and breathe
and let it flow and little longer so
this might be some feet you know a few
days of practicing and the circles with
your hands can start getting smaller so
you'll start really short play big
circles and with some practice you'll
start having longer and longer play and
smaller circles until you're doing this
and guys you put one leg in from the
other so you don't they can really walk
you from the beginning here's the thing
this is a huge trap you can avoid
falling into from the beginning keep
alternating either the right on top and
the left on top and also going inward so
down the middle and outwards so up the
middle with all of us because if you
want to ultimately dance freely which is
probably why you're taking this course
you need outwards and inwards because
I'm facing the water it's inwards if I
turn the fish you is outwards and so you
need to practice
all the variables so it will come it
will so completely totally come you see
the practices of it Sharkboy inwards
outwards slowly you'll be letting to
play it longer and the circles can get
smaller it just really relaxed breathe
enjoy it feel the rhythm and in no time
at all you'll be going like this and the
only thing right now try not to do this
when you if you end up just bouncing
them don't cross your hands figure out
how to let them write together or have
them on their own sides a little bit I
bounce bounce bounce will keep coming
back to this and making it more smooth
and better and more control on all the
things but that will totally get you
straight it
[Music]